so here it is this is it this is the
oculus rift today Facebook and oculus
officially unveiled the rift virtual
reality headset in San Francisco light
you can hold it with one hand the device
will hit shelves in early 2016 and will
pair in a way with Microsoft's Windows
10 operating system pricing hasn't been
set but oculus has previously said it
will cost less than $1500 since
acquiring oculus last year Facebook is
touted rift as a way to transform social
networking at least initially the
headset will be used primarily for
gaming a point underscored by today's
keynote
this is oculus touch these are going to
take virtual reality gaming to the next
level the company also showed off a pair
of prototype hand controllers that will
allow users to put their virtual hands
in the virtual world users could shoot
virtual guns or pick up virtual stuff I
could not only navigate the digital
universe they could become a part of it
and that is at least a small first step
towards the kind of virtual reality
social networking envisioned by Facebook